I just learned that Trevor hasty who is
one of the author's calls in gloom net
and I've never heard it called that
before so it saves a few syllables but
anyway I'm going to talk to you about
Python implementation of elastic net
regularized generalized linear models so
I know that's a mouthful and I'm going
to be spending most of this talk
unpacking that title okay Oh first I'm
going to tell you about linear models
and then how did you as linear models
and then say a few things about
regularization and then talk to you
about a specific form of regularization
called elastic Nets but before I move on
with I just want to note that in data
analysis and data science we live in a
continuum of ideas and there's something
of a trickle-down where you have you
know algorithm developers like hasty and
CAPTCHA Ronnie who are the authors of
GLM and inventors of elastic net and
then you have software developers like
the scikit-learn guys and then you have
our Tichenor who use these to apply for
wide range pipe insights and so I'm
going to assume I the way I structured
this talk is to assume that we don't
have scikit-learn let's say there's an
apocalypse and tomorrow everything is
the same except we don't have psychic so
what I'm gonna talk about how we can
sort of DIY I don't GLM net okay so
generalized linear models but oh okay
do you mean the loom in the text okay
well then so that's not meant to be read
yeah yeah yeah just so you just read the
title but this is just a start off ha
you know Google Scholar search for
generalized linear models this is
something that's existed for over 40
years and generalized linear models are
generalized versions of special cases
like linear regression and logistic
regression and I just put it out there
to tell you that it's been cited over
5,000 time but it's a very versatile and
popular tool for our data analysis
fast forward of you and you have which
is an algorithm for regularizing these
models I'll tell you regularly what
regularization is in a minute but again
you can see this extremely popular one
has close to file you also have a very
robust kitchen R which has close to
4,000 3,000 citation although these are
widely used tools if you look at the
special cases generalized linear models
you have only normal so linear
regression and logistic regression
that's available in psychedlic with
elastic net regularization but often you
have problems where you need to do
Poisson regression or mattina
multinomial regression of action for
which we don't have tools in Python so
PI J LM not aimed to address like yeah
okay so why is it that I built
pi j LM net so I'm a computational
neuroscientist and I thought because
it's PI data I can show it on pi day so
this it's what I work with a bunch of
other computational you know scientists
and in our day job is we want to
understand how the brain works and in
particular we want to relate what
happens in the environment and behavior
to brain activity
so I dip
like this we have a lot of operators and
so when we put we put a monkey in the
lab and we showed some environmental
stimuli in this case a visual stimulus
but the monkey can also control it
joystick which controls the cursor on
the screen so when it moves the joystick
the cursor can move on the screen and so
we give it a bunch of tasks the actual
details of the tasks are not that you
know we have a quantification of the
environmental stimuli so we chose from
the visual similar and then we also
record its movement occasion of its
behavior and we wanted to neural
activity and to be specific the types of
neural data that I work with are spike
things so when we record from the brain
we record voltages from the
extracellular matrix in the brain and so
each spike is a discrete event it's
change in what cell we went through
which is community in the brain
communicate with each other oh the most
standard way to do neural data analysis
is to take a narrow time window of
interest let it see in the little box
there and you count the number of spike
so we have all kinds of features and we
want to use those features to predict
count data and cos best model as Poisson
process so we also have constant is
ticks in the real world and to give you
a more germane example you know we all
develop software and contribute to
github repositories and sometimes we
wonder why certain repositories have
more stars than others and so if we want
to build a model we have to predict a
target variable that's measured as a
count and so we can model that with
Poisson regression right so we can
imagine a bunch of features that we want
to use to predict this small so let me
give you a concrete example of the data
that we work with going back to these
are a couple of example near
okay candy can you hear me clearly
that's that better bett better okay okay
so going back to a couple neurons you
see spike what you see here on the
y-axis as spike comes and on the x-axis
is arm and what you see here is in this
particular neuron you don't have that
much variability but in this particular
neuron the nature of the variability is
nonlinear so if you use vanilla linear
regression you're gonna get a a bad fit
to the data but also linear regression
is not going to be able to predict spike
counts that always have to be positive
and instead if you fit a Poisson
regression you are able to capture the
non-linearity in the relationship
between velocity in spy comms but you're
also able to ensure that the prediction
is always positive furthermore
generalized linear models you can sample
data from once you fit the model and you
can see that if you draw samples from a
model that's been fit you see that the
sample data and the two data have a much
better match for the Poisson regression
so without going the details
there's just kale divergence is a way to
compare two distribution then you can
see the divergence is much smaller okay
so this is just a motivate to you the
importance of Poisson regression for
people like us
yeah having said that I want to kind of
start with the math and walk you through
how we go from using a regression to
generalizing linear regression so most
of you have encountered this in previous
talks so in linear regression you have a
bunch of predictors let's say you have P
predictors and then you have a target
variable of Y and so when you want to
build a model you go out there and
collect observations so let's say you
have n observations and you can write
that out in matrix form as
why hat which is a prediction is some
bias term beta z o plus a matrix of your
observations times predictors n by P
matrix multiplied by the weight factor
that you wanna estimate beta right so
you can write you can write that in two
lines of Python code number you can just
do a matrix multiplication with X and
beta and then add the bias term and
that's your predict function right so
now you want to estimate these and the
most standard way to estimate these
parameters given the data is to use
something like a mean squared loss and
many of you are familiar with the mean
square law so I'm just writing that out
here where you have the prediction Y hat
and the true data Y and then you take
this square and you take the mean of
that some of that you take the mean and
then you can write the same out in
matrix form as an inner product between
the error and it's up right and so you
can see that that's a loss function that
we can then optimize to estimate the
parameters and so I define the loss
function in three lines of Python code
you write them you compute the
prediction and compute the error and you
compute being a product of the error
with itself and that's your last
function so before we proceed does
anybody know why we use the mean square
loss for linear regression
yeah it's it's convex it's easy to
estimate but also a the mean square loss
is the negative log likelihood of a
model which has normally distributed
nice so you can write out the same
linear regression in a probabilistic
form where you assume that in addition
to the model you have some random noise
and the noise can be normally
distributed so this this symbol here
just tells you that you have some
normally distributed knives with zero
mean and some diagnosed of variance and
so given that model you can write out
the probability of observing your target
variables given the predictors and so
this is just the PDF of the Gaussian
distribution so you have an exponent
term and you have a term within the
exponent there is the PDF and I'm just
leaving out all the aspects of the PDF
that don't depend on the Vedas right so
given that you have a number of
observations and assuming that each of
those observations are independent you
can just multiply all those
probabilities together and that's where
you get this product from right so this
is the likelihood of observing the data
of observing the data given the
predictors and if you take the log of
this and the negative of the log you see
that it looks exactly the same as what
we saw here the mean square loss right
so the mean square loss is the negative
log likelihood loss and we're just gonna
use this simple idea to generalize from
linear regression to generalize linear
models okay so again for linear
regression this is the model and you can
just rewrite that as the a at the target
variables Y being normally distributed
with a mean function which is given by
the linear regression model and some
some variants some diagnosed variants
right so this is a special case of
generalized linear models so what do we
do to go from linear regression to GLM's
we take this normal
tribution and we replaced that with a
more general form normal distribution is
just a special case of a distribution in
the exponential family so you can
replace a normal distribution with an
exponential family it has some mean
function and some other parameters the
other thing that you do is you can add a
non-linearity so linear regression you
just have a linear term but here you can
on top of that you have a point wise
non-linearity over the linear term so
you literally do two things to go from
linear regression you add a point where
it's non-linearity and you change the
nice situation right so we'll see we'll
see a special case of this and we can go
back to Poisson regression and you'll
see how what those two assumptions are
you make those two assumption then you
get a special case right
so in the case of Poisson distribution
we assume that the non-linearity is an
exponential right and you can just
rewrite the predict function by adding
an exponential term here that's it and
then you can also assume a certain nice
distribution so you assume that the Y is
a Poisson random variables with a mean
lambda where the lambda is modeled by
this non-linearity right so with these
two assumptions you can now write out
the same loss function that we wrote for
linear regression you can write out the
negative log lucky right so this is the
PDF of the Poisson distribution you can
write the problem to the likelihood and
it's gonna look like that you can remove
the parameters that don't depend on
lambda and then you take the log of that
and you take the negative and so this
becomes your negative log level which is
the loss function right so you can
rewrite your loss function for this
special case of Poisson regression
essentially I'm just writing two lines
of code to say Sigma iyr love life why I
hat minus y hat right and that's your
loss function here and you can do this
over and over again for different
special cases but in the interest of
time I'll just leave these on the slides
and move forward okay so
just to recap we've defined linear
regression we've defined what J lands
are by making those two assumptions
about non-linearity and Narcisco bution
now we need to estimate the parameters
right so in every single machine
learning model that you have looked at
through the conference or any machine
learning model that you use you always
have to do optimization to find the
parameters that minimize the loss
function right so if you recall your
calculus 101 in order to find the
minimum of a function with respect to
some parameters you take the derivative
and you set it to zero so let's do that
for linear regression you take the
derivatives you set it to zero and you
get a system of equations so let's say
you have P predictors and one beta term
for each predictor this is going to give
you a system of linear equations alright
and it so happens that for linear
regression this derivative is linear in
beta so this is a whole set of linear
equations and you solve those linear
equations and you get your optimal
estimates of beta and beta zero right so
you can just write a function to
calculate these derivatives we call them
gradients and this is like a like piece
of code so you just it's it's really
just the error term and the enough the
matrix product between the transpose of
your predictors and the error term and
so you can you can write that out right
now you can do the same for another case
logistic regression I won't walk you
through all the math here but I just
want to point out that this is no longer
a linear equation this is a much more
complicated form and so you don't have a
closed form solution so when you have a
system of linear equations you can
easily compute a closed form solution
but you can do that in all special cases
right but you can still write out the
gradient of the loss function just as we
did here you can write out the gradient
right so if you can't compute the
solution in closed form how do we
optimize it anybody want to take a guess
gradient descent right gradient design
that's really the core engine behind
every optimization algorithm and so what
do you do in gradient descent you say oh
I don't know what the right solution is
for the minimum but I'm going to take a
guess I'm going to start from a starting
point so let me guess that this is an
example it's just like a quadratic
function that you want to minimize but
I'm going to guess that my initial
solution is there so then I compute the
gradient and the gradient in this case
is just the is just the derivative which
looks like this tangent function right
and so you can see straight away that
you see that the this tangent is
pointing downward so the slope is
negative right so this is going to be a
negative term there's going to be a
negative term right and then you have
something called a learning rate
where you decide how far to make a step
in the direction against the grading
that's where you have this negative sign
so you're going to move this is a
negative term and you have a negative
sign and you're going to put those two
together and you've got to move in the
positive in a positive direction so
let's make one update you make another
you make an update and you move the
solution closer to the minimum you do
the same thing over and over again you
make five updates you make fifteen
updates by the time you do 50 updates
you have converged at the optimal
solution so that is gradient descent
right so this is the fit function that
you all for your scikit-learn algorithm
if you were to write you know a fit
function for an estimator
this is what it would look like okay so
this p is just it's telling you how many
predictors there are and you can get
that from your X and then you initialize
your parameters to some random
initialization make sure you normalize
them to have you know to sum up to 1 and
then you iterate over a finite number of
iterations that you can pass as a
parameter and then in each iteration you
compute the gradients so remember we
wrote these gradient function three it's
like and then you just take a step along
the direction of the gradient in each
iteration and once it's
done looking through you returned the
best estimate right so that's it the in
five line of code you have the fit
function for reading this end for a wide
range of models okay
so we're almost done we're halfway
through the title we have defined linear
models generalized linear models but now
we need to understand what elastic net
regular extras
okay so regularization is the idea that
if you have finite amount of data but
you have a large number of predictors of
features or hypotheses or whatever you
want to call them you're going to do
exceedingly well on predicting the
finite training data but then if I give
you some new samples test data then your
prediction is gonna be poor on the test
set right so the idea of regularization
is that let's say you have two different
models one with three predictors and one
with Q predictors
so if use much larger than PN it's just
subsumes all these predictors then in
general this is gonna do much better on
your training set and therefore you need
to make sure that you penalize more
complex model than summary so the idea
of regularization is to just add a
penalty term your negative log
likelihood loss function itself so
instead of minimizing just that log
likelihood which measures the goodness
of fit of your model to data right you
add a penalty term and the most classic
penalty to use is to take the sum of
squares of all your weights and the idea
of the end this is called l2
regularization and so this loss function
is called the L to penalise loss
function it's also called Ridge
regression it's called different things
in but you add this parameter and then
you repeat the same thing so you can
define the l2 loss function and you can
compute the gradient of that you already
have the gradient of the loss and to
that you just add the gradient of this
term right and then you're done once you
have the loss function the gradient you
know how to write the fit function
because you just have your gradients in
your date time and each iteration right
so let's actually take some simulated
data and look at what happens
when you do and when you don't regularly
so the the the when you add this penalty
term you have a parameter called lambda
and that's called the regularization
parameter so let's see what happens when
lambda is extremely large right the loss
function is dominated by this term and
when lambda is extremely small the loss
function is dominated by this number so
one is dominated by this term it cares
only about fitting to the training data
but when it's dominated by this term it
doesn't care about the fit at all and it
just wanna push all your parameters
close to zero so what we do in practice
to estimate lambda is we take the
training data we split it into a subset
and then a validation a training sub
training set and a validation set and
then we sweep through a range of lambdas
to find what the best lambda is and so
what you see on the left here is a plot
of the goodness of fit like a score
function or a square of the training
data and the test data the training data
in red and the validation data in green
against the values of lambda so and
there's a logarithmic scale so you see
you see it varies for very small values
of lambda you get a really good fit to
the training set but then when you
showed the validation set it does pretty
poorly right so this gap between these
two curves the red and the and the green
curves is a measure of the extent to
which your model over fits but then as
you sweep through the lambdas you
increase the lambdas the prediction on
the on the red curve is going worse on
the training set is getting worse but on
the test set is getting better so you
want to stop and choose the lambda at
the at which your prediction on the
validation set is the best and so this
this is called cross-validation and you
do this all the time to select your
optimal regularization so this is good
for problems where you have a large
number of you have a lot of data but
also large number of parameters
and here you see that in black you see
the different parameter values the true
Boehner values and in red you see the
estimated beta values so you see that
way because of regularization the
estimated beta value pushed closer so
this is nice to have because you don't
want to wait something too heavily that
the and risk overfitting your training
data but it's not so useful in scenarios
where you have a large number of
hypotheses a large number of predictors
but only a small number of them are
actually useful in the prediction
problem and this happens all the time in
biology so if you look at problems in
genetics for instance where you know you
have your measurement of 5,000 genes
let's say but only two or three of them
are relevant to that particular cancer
type so let's call the sparse scenario
where you have only a few predictors
that matter for your problem then you
won't know want to use something like
rich regression instead a very common
technique is called lasso regression or
l1 penalty but what you do is you take
the absolute values of the weights and
then you make you add that as the family
instead of the squared instead of the
square town you take the absolute values
so what this does is is something very
different so instead of uniformly
pushing all the weights to zero
penalizing by using the absolute value
makes a lot of the weights go to zero
and leave very few weights to be nonzero
right and so you can define your as as
before you can define your loss function
a single line of code but let's go back
to our example and compare the
difference between ridge regression and
lasso regression so you have 200
observations but you have 500 predictors
and what you see up on top is the same
figure that you saw earlier in red is
the goodness of fit or the R square on
the training set and in green is the
goodness of fit on the validation set
and you see that rich does really poorly
because it continues to die even though
you increase lambda a lot continue
to fit very well on the training set but
extremely poorly on the validation set
and so the gap between these two lines
is still very large even as we increase
lambda right but by comparison you see
the same figure for lasso regression and
you see that these curves meet already
when you have a modest value of lambda
right so lasso regression is much better
in scenarios where you have only a few
nonzero weights so again what you see
here in black are you know true weights
the true parameters of the model and in
red the estimated parameters so if you
here you can see a few failure mode of
Ridge regression where most of the
weights and like squash to zero and it's
not really doing a good job of
generalizing but by comparison you see
the red dots here and most of them are
set to zero but it still correctly
identifies a couple of the parameters in
fact this a couple of parameters that
are most important in the prediction
incorrectly identified slopes and so
table the general is fairly well to the
descent
okay so that was preamble about
regularization Ridge regression and
lasso regression now I'm coming back to
the title of the town so elastic math is
kind of a nice way to interpolate
between the advantages of regulation and
laceration right so all you do is they
call that English in in Ridge you had
the squared squared loss and in lasso
regression we had the absolute loss and
so you say oh I don't exactly know how
much I should use these two but I'm
gonna use another parameter called alpha
which is sometimes known as the l1 ratio
so you say I'm gonna wait this l1 goes
by alpha and we have two lost by one
minus alpha and that's your elastic net
penalty and so you again you add that
penalty to the negative log likelihood
and you get your elastic net loss again
you can write that out in the same way
and so once you have your loss you have
your gradient of the loss you can go
back your fit function and do the same
gradient descent and solving so at this
point I should say
that's it the talk is done right but if
you vote if you go and look at the art
package there's a bunch of different
tricks that they use to make the
technique work and some of this actually
comes from failure advanced optimization
theory so at this point I just want to
check how much time I have
hey um so maybe I can pause for a minute
or two minutes to take questions before
I proceed with advanced optimization
yeah
yeah yeah that's that's a really good
question so there are at least two
different ways to interpret that one of
them is that you're doing something
Bayesian here which is you know if you
have the likelihood you have the
negative log likelihood you don't really
make any assumptions about what the
parameter should look like but the
moment you add a penalty term any
penalty okay so you can think of that
penalty as a prior on the weights so
when you when you actually go back so
this is the negative this is the
negative log likelihood right so when
you take this entire term and you go
back from negative log likelihood to
likelihood you're gonna see that it's
actually a product of two different
probability distributions and it turns
out that this probability distribution
is you know going to correspond to let's
say in linear regression is going to
correspond to the PDF of a normal
distribution right but if you take this
probability distribution is going to
correspond to prior on the mean of the
probability of the normal distribution
right so if you use a square loss you're
using a normal prior if you use the
absolute loss you are using what is
called a laplacian front and what is the
laplacian final do it selects model so
effect a Gaussian distribution looks
something like that right a laplacian
distribution looks something like this
so you can think of it they sometimes
call it stick and slab fire so you have
a stick that's close to zero you have a
lot of problem building mass that's
close to zero and you have long tails so
you're gonna have very few values no
probability mass but still greater
probability mass and the tails than a
Gaussian distribution so that you can
get very few large values but you're
going to get the most value very so
that's that's a Bayesian interpretation
you have any other questions before I
proceed to is that it's all making sense
so I'm going to tell you about four
tricks that you don't really fix they're
actually very theoretically grounded
things but it's not taught in
optimization 101 class and so I really
have to spend a lot of weekends and
nights digging through these papers
before I figure them out but if you look
at this term right the absolute value we
call that when when we do gradient
descent you have a loss term and you
then you have to compute the gradient
with respect to the loss this absolute
value function is not differentiable at
0 right so if you don't if you have a
function is not differentiable at 0 or
it's not differentiable everywhere where
you're interested in how do you take the
gradient right so that's the first trick
that they use they use a technique
called projected video so in projected
gradient what you do is you take the
gradient of everything else except this
term which you cannot differentiate and
then you apply what's called a
projection operator so you do the
gradient update as always and then this
projection operator what it does is it
does something called software showing
so if you have a projection function of
X with respect to some threshold for
lambda is basically you take the value X
if the absolute value of X is larger
than lambda or if it's smaller than
minus lambda then you shrink it by
lambda so you basically shifted toward 0
by lambda so you do this and then if if
it's larger than lambda you do that but
if it's smaller than lambda you push it
down to 0 so that's let's call the
predicted gradient and I won't get into
the theory of why that works but it's a
pretty simple technique and you do that
after we update Stephanie
guarantees right so in the way that they
were way to implement that in Python is
you just define the soft threshold
function and then instead of doing the
typical gradient descent update where
you take the learning rate times the
gradient you also do you push it through
this proximal operation right so that's
one luck this one line of course that
you need to change okay that's one trick
but as a result of this trick you can do
a lot of other cool things so one of the
things that you do is you typically
sweep I recall that in regularization I
said you can sweep through a range of
lambda and select your optimal lambda so
that's called the regularization path
but in practice what they do something
called warm restarts so they select the
largest value of lambda which is gonna
push from the majority of the weights
down to zero and then the initialize
subsequent solution for the next land up
with the optimal solution for the
previous lambda and what that does is it
dramatically speeds convergence because
you're starting with an extremely good
guess of what your solution is fine so
that's called warm restarts and and
that's that's again pretty easy to
implement because you just store elektra
dictionary off your solutions from the
previous value of lambda and then before
you start your optimization you just
initialize with the previous value of
lambda all right so that's another trick
the third trick is also really
interesting and also speeds of
conversion it's called the active set
rate so recall that in the projected
gradient method if you have small values
values smaller than lambda if one has
pushed them down to zero right so what
the active set technique does is
maintains an active set of all the
lambdas that are nonzero and then at
each iteration in your gradient descent
you only update the nonzero times so
imagine that if you have a set of
thousand predictors right now
in a typical lasso problem elastic net
problem you're gonna have maybe 800 800
of those of 0 so all during the first
iteration if you identify maybe
100 of those who get pushed down to zero
you only need to update the remaining
300 so in the number of iterations
required for convergence becomes
romantically faster because in each
iteration you throw away the values that
are already set to zero and you me
updates a non zero and the final trick
is actually is to do something better
than vanilla gradient descent so because
a large number of values are getting set
to zero by you know things like active
sag and AFTRA shoaling you can you can
actually cycle through the updates the
parameters one parameter editor so
recall that in gradient descent if you
have 100 parameters you compute the
gradient respect to all the 100 and then
you make one update but important it is
and what you do is I go through all the
coordinates one coordinate at a time and
again this is much faster because in if
you have an active set that's rapidly
shrinking from 1,000 to 300 to 30 then
you only have to do that many cycles of
your coordinate descent
so that's they do that and the other
thing that they do is to use a Newton
update so Newton update
I don't wanna in the interest of time
I'll skip exactly what that is but I do
have a notebook table on the repo that
you can go to try and understand the
difference between when you love
gradient descent and you do nothing but
what Newton update does essentially is
reading this and Molly tells you the
direction in which you wanna hit you
have to still a similarly way in Newton
Newton's method you can do much better
than just guessing the learning rate you
can actually get a much better estimate
of how much the moment depending on
local curvature information right so
they use Newton's method as well in
cyclic coordinate descent so I think I'm
coming to the end of my list of tricks
that epsilon e HT are used to speed up
the R package and all of these are
implemented now in Phi G element package
the only thing that remains to be
to translate some of the most critical
components from Mike on this icon and
that's something I'm actively working on
but before I conclude I wanted to say
that we you know an optimization and
machine learning we work a lot with
gradients so we worked a lot with
calculus and all of the differentiation
the matrix
there are differentiation that have told
you about I've done by pen and paper on
a whiteboard right
but you can also take advantage of
symbolic differentiation packages that
Python gives you so this is it there is
a package called simple which is like
mathematical for some of you -
Mathematica but here's like a little
snippet of code I have with more details
on this in Python but what simply is in
essence lets you do is initially lets
you initially symbolically write and
then it has functions like diff so you
initialize your symbols X X Y x1 y1 x1
x2 y beta0 beta1 beta2 like just a toy
problem to illustrate simple price and
then you have your prediction and then
you compute the loss there is no
computation going on and these are all
symbolic variables and then when you do
the differentiation you also have like
an additional simplified function than
this and it cleans up your algebra you
can do that and then it just gives you
what derivative and you can do let me
use this to check your math so like I
have like a linear regression example
logistic regression example in water so
that's that's one advantage of simple
but of course Theano is also our friend
and we have you know advanced cancer
libraries like Keanu or and tensor flow
which do one better they don't just let
you check your math they take away the
job for you and dutifully so that's
called automatic differentiation and
it's a it's a very old field but it's
become extremely mature and libraries
make ya know and so I just we
implemented linear regression in Siana
on in this slide and I'm just gonna
leave them here and you can look through
the Tianna notebook but I'll briefly
point out it's essentially a similar
idea is simple so you have symbolic
variables
and then you can do all your operations
symbolically like you you initialize
shared variables for for your parameters
that you did and then in just these two
lines of code if you define your GL m so
what is this line of code - it computes
the prediction
this is like the predict function and
then this is the loss function right
it's just these two lines of code but
the amazing thing about automatic
differentiation is you don't have to
write gradient of the loss you just say
PR now dot tensors or granny
and you say I want to compute the
gradient of the loss with respect to and
that already gives you symbolic right so
it's just these two lines of code if I
want to implement logistic regression I
just have to change the predict function
and I have to change the loss function
changes to the logistic loss and that's
it I'm done so tiana can and then you
compile this and then you fit the model
and you predicted right so you just have
like to compile function one is called
fit and the other is called predict and
if you just simply tell it that you know
I this is my data X and 1 and these are
the things that I want the function to
return the prediction and the loss and
in each step I want you to update the
parameters according to the gradients so
in five lines of code yang can do all
the work of the fit in the function and
actually if you're interested in
automatic differentiation Indiana there
is a library called SK learn piano which
is reimplemented some of the most useful
scikit-learn functions in piano and
that's something you can go take a look
at but yeah piano is very mature library
and it's fairly easy to use although I
hear that the error handling is not
happy error bug reporting is not as good
but it's it's it's a really powerful
automatic
so that concludes the the theory part of
the talk and I just want to briefly say
that you know you can go look on the
repo but it's all object oriented and
all the methods live in one single class
called GLM and all of the dark strings
you know conform to the dog string which
gives you the help for the class and
methods all conform to second standards
so you have all the parameters I think
you have here you have like maybe 10 or
15 parameters for the class
there are fit and predict and score
methods just like for any estimator
scikit-learn and there's also simulate
method that is convenient for drawing
samples from the fit models and then the
other advantage is since we always fit
this in a regularization path sweeping
through the lambda you can also slice
the estimator so if by default it fits
through for default range of lambdas and
so if you want the prediction for one
particular thing in this slicing but
anyway I won't bore you with the
implementation and details and the API
details there's a good documentation
page take a look at the documentation
and pretty much there all the math that
I told you about in the talk is
available in the tutorial there's also a
small example gallery the demonstrates
probably a theorized world how
benchmarks with respect to my GL m9 and
scikit-learn
certain cycle on implementation some
benchmarks between 5g Lebanon and are
all of those we are starting to handles
and there's also a little bit of
developer documentation if you want to
help me because I'm pretty much the
developer team here except for a few
friends who pitched in and so you're
welcome to look at the developer
documentation contribute and so I think
I'm going to summarize
theirs so we learned that the mean
square loss is a special case of the
negative
and then we learned that we can define
GLM's by going from linear regression
and assuming a non-linearity or then
assuming and once more we learn about
regularization and we learn about how to
define elastic net as a combination of
the rich and lasso regression and then
we learn about optimization techniques
using gradient descent and all kinds of
other advanced optimization tools that
tasty and tips irani use and finally
remember that sin Phi and tiana we use
tools to make sure you don't so like to
stop here go check out the slides in the
notebooks there on the repo you can
prune the library and start playing
around applying here data and go look at
this should we post feature requests and
yeah yeah that's that's on the cards
yeah especially if we want to scale up
the large data sets I think it'd be good
to use fantastic very innocent I mean my
first step is I want to evaluate whether
saikhan versus piano is gonna give me
the best step in terms of speed up
because if I choose to use piano then
all the stochastic gradient descent
methods are already implemented in the
optimizer
you